why would anything that makes you happy
and doesn't hurt anybody else be wrong
no matter what you want to be in life
and no matter what you want to do
whether it be you know a dog trainer or
a kickboxer or a zoo owner it takes
certain amounts of passion time and
dedication network connections power
money
That's What Makes You free money buys
health care and if you think you have
health care you do not that's what I
would say is the most crazy thing about
having money trying to make them notice
you and and realize your usefulness
don't try to tell them that you're
useful then I'm in a position
where I was very lucky to have a good
father figure and an older brother in my
life to guide me
over some of the hurdles that young men
face but a lot of hurdles that you know
young men face they haven't got anybody
to look up to and they haven't got
anybody to turn to and I thought you
know what let me just give this little
bit of Life advice out to the younger
men out there he said I broke up with my
ex
um she's asking me to refer me back how
do I know if it's too late to take her
back or or should I take her back or
should I not take her back uh take her
back
the answer to whether you or not you
should take an ex-girlfriend back is
very simple and I know this and most
fully grown men I probably know this
um but for the younger guys out there
let me explain to you exactly what it is
if she has had another boyfriend or
another sexual partner or another
relationship since the breakup it is too
late to take her back it is over at that
point because no matter what happens in
the relationship no matter if you get
married have kids if you stay together
for a very long time because it didn't
that all happened because it didn't work
out with the guy who she was with after
your breakup so you are always going to
be Plan B you're always going to be the
fallback guy you're always going to be
the idiot that's always there so if
she's had a week or two and you know
hung out with her girlfriends and cried
into her pillow by all means take her
back the moment there's been another guy
in the scene at all she's only
interested in taking you back and
getting back with you because it didn't
work out with him so don't let yourself
be
um played like that yeah don't be second
place to anybody so that's when it's too
late I think that the
real
definition of right and wrong actions or
whether they cause other people harm
and I think that's everybody's
definition
I'm 34. you're exactly the same age as
me I am too working on myself trying to
build myself up working on my finances
although they're pretty secure I'm
always trying to do better and I I care
about taking care of my mother too yeah
I'm certainly not uh chasing tail around
like I was when I was 21 because you
know I've realized as I'm older and
smarter that there are better things to
do
you are going to need a woman because
you are going to need kids and having
kids is a very important mission in any
man's life so yeah by all means work on
yourself I don't understand why that
would be a negative thing that's
actually a very beautiful thing
being truly honest living only for
yourself and not taking the time and the
the the financial commitment to take the
time commitment it takes to procreate I
think would be of ultimately very
unhappy life shared blood is the best uh
you know it's the best way of securing
loyalty so as a man who's building an
empire I don't see how I could justify
continue my life if I was not trying to
procreate and have children but yeah
having having a daughter and being a
father is absolutely
no 22 year old
should be on any kind of steroid I can
see cases
for testosterone replacement therapy for
people in their upwards of 40 maybe
maybe uh late 30s I could see the case
for that uh for upping your testosterone
level trying to get your energy levels
back to when you were much younger do
you exercise regularly do you eat right
how much alcohol do you drink do you
smoke you know why don't you look at
what testosterone is look at your your
current life and uh the the and your
current habits and try to up your
testosterone level naturally there's no
excuse to be injecting anything into
your in arms at this age I think that's
really pathetic I believe that the time
to get wealthy wealthy in an easy and a
quick way has run out already I'm going
to tell you why we've all heard of the
Gold Rush haven't we
Gold Rush was a time when in certain
rivers in California large nuggets of
gold were found
and people went nuts people all moved
out to California and lots of people got
very rich because it was gold in the
hills and everyone was paying for gold
searching the rivers for gold mining for
gold a gold horse has just happened and
the Gold Rush we've just seen is the
easy money there was to make in
crypto coins
um Bitcoin has a use case ethereum has a
use case chain link and a few other
cryptos have a use case and they're
going to last well long into the future
they might even be the future of
currency people who own them now might
be the richest people in the world in
five or ten years but I'll tell you what
isn't going to exist
[Music]
pump and dump crypto nonsense coins that
kids can buy for a few thousand dollars
and become millionaires overnight the
time of easy money is over the Gold Rush
is over there's no more easy money in
the way there used to be there's no way
you're gonna draw a little pixelated
picture of a monkey or banana or pig or
a ninja and sell it for six hundred
thousand dollars anymore The nft Craze
is over that goes to show that the Easy
Money days in crypto are completely over
so getting wealthy is possible it's
always been possible and during the
worst recessions in the world people
have made money getting rich possible
again but it's going to take a lot more
hard work than it's ever taken before
the days of the free money on the
internet have ended absolutely you eat
McDonald's every day you know not to do
that so you're trying to get into the
specifics without covering the basics
you know what I mean it's like when
people care about Fitness okay what's
the exact correct technique to lift this
and lift that people who don't drink at
all just go running and do some bushes
everyone knows like the answers step one
stop eating my goggles every day yeah
like that that once you do that worry
more about the exact specifics of what
you're eating right here three and a
half thousand calories in a single meal
once a day yeah that's better than all
the time that's what I do in the
afternoon not before so I always go to
sleep a bit hungry you know I know I
have breakfast in the morning at least
yeah I don't even realize I do it it's
always it's how I live
this is why I don't read self-help books
uh I believe that that is Success porn
we've been reading these books about get
rich and do well how many people do I
know who've read these books and never
got rich zero zero when they think about
reading helps you reading is
entertainment so if you read the James
Bond novels for entertainment it's
better than watching the James Bond
movies I believe that it's a higher form
of entertainment than Netflix and TV but
it's essentially just Netflix for the
brain so um yeah reading is a waste of
time if you want to get rich I agree but
there is one TV show which I'm going to
talk about now and we never talk about
it on an emergency meeting live
because my brother has not seen this yet
but I was at somebody's house
about three years ago four years ago and
I watched episode one of a show which
has 11 series to it and it was so
excellent
that I've watched all of it now I
believe this TV show to be a
intellectual and cultural Masterpiece
and it is the greatest show that has
ever ever been broadcast on television
and I'm talking of course
about the show Trailer Park Boys
um the importance of Brotherhood and
friendship and sticking together is a
massive underlying theme of the show
um also
the importance of enjoying your current
circumstances keep working keep hustling
keep grinding try and get out but enjoy
yourself while you're at it it's a show
about perseverance it's a show about
trying to always
better your situation besides that TV's
a waste of time
especially the news